let's go back to the phones which are no
longer phones we now take calls via
Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and hear from a few more people
why don't we go to money from the United
Kingdom from where I have just returned
Moni welcome to the program
hi uh how was your trip to the UK did
you actually go to Brighton in the end I
did not I ended up going to Bath in the
end
okay still a nice place yeah quite
interesting and you know the weather was
very shaky uh I actually I had an insane
situation where I was walking uh near
kind of near uh Regents Park in London
and it was so windy that my hotel
umbrella reversed have you've seen an
umbrella reverse right
oh like every couple weeks yeah yeah so
my umbrella reversed and it was I was
trying to hold on to the baby stroller
and the umbrella reversal was dragging
me around and these British girls walked
by and were laughing hysterically and it
I mean the the but then
you know they should help you they
should have helped me I know they said
beautiful day for a walk that was their
joke as I was all right wrestling to try
to keep the stroller and the umbrella
under control
you should say that the weather here is
awesome today oh yeah I saw that the day
I left it got better but anyway what
what can I do for you sir
um I just wanted to call in and say that
in the last like few I believe it's been
a few weeks now maybe even a month I
have do you agree that I I think that
this is possibly the biggest movement
for gun control in the US that I've seen
really uh since the uh
uh the two well they ended the
2004-2005 uh assault weapons ban I have
never seen uproar like this coming out
of I think it was the state of Tennessee
wasn't it you know it was I I want to
feel the same way you're feeling Moni
which is wow look at this isn't it we've
never seen momentum like this before it
seems inevitable that something's going
to be done but every time we think that
we're so disappointed like after the
Sandy Hook shooting about 11 years ago
it was like wow we're gonna pass
Universal background checks it's just
gonna happen and of course it it didn't
and you can go all the way back to the
civil rights movement of the 60s and 70s
and the assassinations of Martin Luther
King and Robert F Kennedy when there
were fewer guns in circulation and it
was like wow we're going to see change
and we did get the gun control act of
1968 regulating the the sale of firearms
and then we went on to have 400 million
guns enter Society in the United States
so I systems so cynical that we're
really going to see change I want to see
it and I hope that you're right
uh yeah me too man it's it's a bit crazy
over there we all see it it really does
the other thing I wanted to say if I do
have the time of course yeah I hope I do
yeah is um that with all these issues
that are going on recently with like the
whole thing of the Democrats planning to
of course put on the ballot uh
supposedly that they are pro-abortion
rights and all other things we've seen
from Donald Trump and all the things
we've seen from run to santis currently
abandoning Florida while it's underwater
do you think that a lot less people are
going to vote Republican in this next
coming election
now when you say that fewer people will
vote Republican do you mean that some
historical Republican voters will vote
for a Democrat or that many Republicans
will just stay home
uh well either really
I don't know the answer to that I mean I
do I do think that if Trump is the
nominee
which is looking quite likely it based
on today's polling I do think that there
is a contingent of the pub Republicans
that are just so sick and tired of the
insanity of trump now under indictment
potentially with more indictments coming
that they are going to throw their hands
up some of them and say listen I'm not
voting for a Democrat but I'm sick of
this Trump crap I'm just staying home I
do think there will be a contingent like
that whether it will influence the
results in any significant way it's just
so early to say
yeah I agree I had a friend from Georgia
who vote Republican most of his life he
actually switched in 2022 because of the
oh and just the abortion rights stuff so
yeah we will see yeah I'll I'll not take
up any more of your time now but thanks
for asking answering my questions all
right money from the UK have a good day
you too great to hear from you uh
absolutely fantastic stuff let's go next
to Louis from New Brunswick Louis from
New Brunswick welcome to the program
hey David
so good to uh to speak with you thanks
for taking the call my pleasure got a
couple questions I noticed on your show
uh could have been a couple days ago
you mentioned that you're leasing a
Tesla so this is more like a financial
question do you generally
um recommend that people lease vehicles
I heard it's a bad financial decision
overall no I recommend that people study
the issue on their own and make their
own decision based on how they tend to
deal with vehicles in their lives uh
leasing makes sense
for some people in very specific
situations one of the things about
leases is that uh they can be
fully tax deductible as a business
expense depending on the use of the
vehicle and how it's structured and that
is like a savings of whatever your
effective tax rate is which can be a
significant savings if you tend to
replace your vehicle with some frequency
leasing can be a much simpler path than
trying to sell a vehicle every few years
which you might be underwater on if
you're financing it and then you have to
deal with repairs or whatever like I
like after three years being able to
just walk away
um for me in particular I mean I'll be
honest I've said before I'm you know
former Tesla shareholder Tesla driver
the the build quality of my Tesla is not
exactly something to write home about
and it's been in the shop a bunch of
times and quite frankly I wouldn't want
to own it like there's a particular
reason with my Tesla I don't want to own
the thing I want to be able to just walk
away and it'll be Elon Musk or someone
else's problem at the end of three years
and at that by then there will be so
many
um other electric vehicles and the
quality will likely have improved and
the range that I'll sort of have like my
pick of the litter is my is my hope so
for for very specific reasons leasing
made sense for me but that doesn't mean
that it makes sense for any other
particular person
got you thank you for the detailed
response all right one more question if
we have time sure do you think there's
any chance that um facing the the threat
or like high possibility of imprisonment
that Donald Trump will flee the country
no it's your personal opinion I don't
believe so
gotcha yep
David it's been a pleasure thanks so
much take care Louie my pla the pleasure
is all on this side of the microphone my
friend I really appreciate that